medic  oh Jesus  Beth we should go  millions of dollars worth of cocaine  fell from the sky this morning in  Knoxville Tennessee there's more this  out there they dumped it somewhere I'm  looking for my daughter's first is a  dangerous place Henry check it out  something got into it a deer Maybe  a lot of cocaine was lost I need you to  go and get it  [Music]  no don't eat that don't eat that let's  see what kind of effect that has  [Music]  the bear it [ __ ] did cocaine  [Music]  we're getting cocaine  bear a bear it was  hey that's inappropriate  [Music]  Chris can't climb trees of course I can  oh [ __ ]  [Music]  it kind of seems like the thing that  stays with a man forever  apex predator  high on cocaine  thought of his mind  oh man you [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong  with that man  [Music]  we have such good luck in nature